it's the first day of the Congress of
China's ruling Communist party and
pro-democracy Hong kongers are
protesting outside the Chinese Consulate
in Manchester
journalists and protesters were filming
and so were the Consular on their CCTV
cameras
they have highlighted their edited
videos using red circles
a peaceful protest descended into
violence it forced police to intervene
on Chinese ground
this is how it unfolded
at 2 38 PM the gate is opened at the
consulate and four staff members walk
out including the consul General Zhang
XI Wen himself
two of them are wearing Riot helmets and
vests
the man in the black and red jacket is
holding something taken from his left
pocket we've been unable to identify
exactly what it is
the console General kicks a banner and
pulls down the other the two men wearing
riot gear pick up and move the cartoon
poster depicting the Chinese president
towards the consulate the protesters
rushed to stop them in the CCTV released
by The consulate they highlight this
protester who ends up inside the grounds
this Consular staff member wearing riot
gear is pulled away knocked to the floor
by the protesters the police who are
parked up the road arrive 20 seconds
after it turns violent
another one of the staff wearing riot
gear is pulled from the consulate gate
and kicked at least three times in the
head by the protesters
one of the most senior Chinese diplomats
in the UK the consul General is now
inside the consulate he's seen here
pulling the hair of one of the
protesters Bob Chan the consulate staff
are pulling Chan inside the grounds the
police officer is trying to pull him out
the staff member in the red jacket is
seen reaching into his pocket again
moments later he's knocked down by
another protester at the gate
the police try to break up the violence
but don't enter the grounds of the
consula
protester Bob Chan has been pulled
further inside the consulate Gates and
is being hit by two of the staff
two police officers are forced to enter
the grounds and attempt to intervene
Chan is eventually removed and the gate
is shut
greater Manchester police is
investigating the incident that lasted
just 70 seconds Chinese officials cannot
be prosecuted due to diplomatic immunity
but pressure is Mountain on the foreign
office to act
the consulate say the protesters were
using offensive slogans and images but
there are calls by MPS and others to
expel those involved
Adam Parker Sky News